[Music]
how's it going everybody Aaron Sampson
here with Alessandro hello we had a
chance to go out to a ranch and shoot
some crossbows and join a cult like any
other Wednesday and also played a bunch
of a co-op far cry 5 and what we want to
bring to you today are our top tests for
far cry coop before the game is even out
for our first test we wanted to see if
you can fly our sport for a friend so
Aaron had the idea to hijack a World War
2 era fighter plane and we went off to
raid a base we basically just went in
like guns blazing like you know I was
like I'm the attack gunner seat in the
back of while he was flying and I
decided to just bail out and just
wingsuit in like go on the ground and I
was like shooting all the bad guys on
the ground and while Aaron was like
flying over me like just shooting like
as much like the facility as he could
were also firing a bunch of missiles and
by the way this attack fighter was a has
been sort of a decked out in a bunch of
modern like a sort of tools of
disruption so it was cool seeing like
you know just the scale the action to
like a I was doing my own thing on the
ground while he was up top and it was it
was pretty crazy seeing a little in
action yeah we were pretty excited that
we could actually fly a close air
support for our real-world friend in
this game the only thing I will say
though is that there's a tether range so
unlike Ghost Recon wildlands you simply
cannot fly past a certain point without
threatening to end a mission so you have
to be very conscious of how far away
from your buddy on the ground you are
so yeah flying air support for your
friend is definitely true you can
definitely do it in this game so the
second test we wanted to do was a little
bit ridiculous a little bit of dangerous
for your health and also a returning
from previous Far Cry games we want to
know if you could grapple a helicopter
that your buddy was flying and swing
your way to the nearest objective and
you had way too much fun doing this too
by the way oh my god yeah I was pretty
much left my ass off the entire time we
were doing this not only that but there
was a great moment where you lowered me
into a base and my biggest failure by
the way I remember landing and saying I
got this and then all I hear is oh my
god and I turn around in your helicopter
just came in and almost domed me when I
get down music I can lower it now I'm
good okay up there we're good
that was brioche it no no I meant a
little lower
I meant alors so hitting the right
button for going up and down and/or
exiting your vehicle is very important
in in Far Cry 5 and for the record this
is all by accident this is not
intentional but I'm usually much better
at the game than this
I think uncontrolled chaos is one of the
things that I love the most about this
game this is probably one of my favorite
moments from our test session so yeah
it's definitely true returning from
previous Far Cry games you can grapple
onto your buddy's helicopter for test
three we were trying to see if Far Cry 5
would be a bit easier with a co-op buddy
so honestly me and Aaron played for like
an hour straight just like messing
around like doing a bunch of missions
and you know we we had to learn again
like keeping in mind sort of the the
tethering of like co-op but he's like
you know we couldn't stray too far from
each other
or else you would receive damage and at
first we were a bit confused by that
because what we thought we were being
attacked at we fell into like a sort of
a dangerous area but that's how the
tethering works and to in order to keep
you the two players together in one
mission we're also trying to figure out
how to effectively save a bunch of
hostages and we failed that mission
twice because my fault yeah Aaron
decided to bail out of a helicopter
while I was using the monocular to scout
ahead and I suddenly saw the mountain
face just slowly coming to you know just
get closer in second time Aaron decided
to throw in the c4 charges some enemies
while also killing the hostages
you hostages Aaron oops my bad but we
got it we got it down the third time
like it worked but uh I definitely found
that some encounters are a bit easier
with the coop buddy but the same time it
feels like the overall game itself is a
bit harder because I found myself using
a lot of met hacks like way more in
higher frequency compared to other Far
Cry games now there are some things that
make your life easier
such as you can respawn now to be fair
guns for hire can do that as well
like even when you get cheeseburger the
murder bear he can actually lick you
back alive it does kind of suck and was
a little bit awkward for things like
wingsuiting and also these clutch nixon
challenges when you're doing this clutch
Nixon challenges like this atv challenge
here when a buddies in here it feels
like you're supposed to be doing it
competitively but you're actually doing
cooperatively which means if one of you
fails or you get too far apart you both
failed a mission that felt off to me
like it felt like when you bring a buddy
in you should be having fun together and
maybe like a little bit of friendly
competition as opposed to getting
worried you get too far ahead of your
buddy and and you just fail so I think
at the end of the day what would you say
was that true or false or coming to true
definitely the the overall
combat itself seems to have been stepped
up a bit and you need you do need to be
a bit more careful with how you engage
certain enemies so I think the end of
the day we gave that one a fat sort of
true
the next test that we did we wanted to
push the limits of the world and see if
maybe it was like a fallout or and other
open world games where you can just
straight-up kill quest givers and maybe
missed parts of the game that was a
pretty easy one we fired up the local
co-op bunker after there's actually a
weird murderous psycho intro you get
with your co-op friend where you you
were like running through and shooting
they almost make it look like you shoot
two other co-op players before you get
you going to go up and you've been
brainwashed to kill it's a it's a whole
weird intro and then after that you go
to a bunker and we just immediately
started chucking c4 at NPCs I was
initially confused when you started
doing this
you didn't quite tell me what you were
doing at first this so I was very
surprised to see like all our quest
givers and you know people supposed to
help us like you know like all on the
ground injured the funny thing is that
you can put them into a down state with
c4 and when you get the backup they'll
say things like well we're glad you're
on our team they're like really they're
happy that you cut them back out which
is a little funny but if you actually
aim a gun at them or you punch them a
couple times before before killing them
they'll actually they'll kill you first
and if you don't have a co-op buddy to
revive you it's probably game over but
to be fair you can sort of kill them
they're very forgiving once you revive
them you definitely cannot kill them all
the way but the guns for hire are
slightly different story
I believe you can all the way kill some
of the cheaper guns for hire that you
find in the world but a guy like Herc
you can accidentally screw up and I'll
dive you just go back to your menu and
and reassign him and he'll come back
which might be a good hack actually
because you can get his his rocket
launcher by doing that so this one was a
bit false because you you can attack
them and they'll get into a down state
but they won't die so and of course
they'll forgive you and like immediately
after you revive them so so for the last
test we wanted to see if you could take
co-op progress with you back into the
single-player game so we played
single-player about an hour and I
invited Aaron into my game and he
basically came into exactly where I was
at which is that hurts a house where we
also got to meet Hertz dad who's a
incredibly conservative dude and not
really welcoming of outsiders and when I
first bought into your game was standing
next to her interesting dad I actually
did have a custom shotgun that came with
me from my single-player experience so
Aaron and I from there just basically
went and just did a bunch of like base
rating like killed a bunch of animals
like flew helicopters it was great
well then afterwards we sort of parted
and I did notice that a certain story
missions that at Aaron like was
referencing wasn't completed on on mine
so the thing that Ubisoft was very clear
in the thesaurus stating was that they
didn't want to create these
inconsistencies between
the narratives they didn't want the the
other player coming in the guest
character sort of skip over big chunks
of the story they wanted to keep the
guest character just that a guest so
they're being invited into the hosts
version of the game and they're staying
there for a bit then they venture back
into their version of the game right
where they left it but one thing that is
clear is that you still retain like new
weapons perks and items you require such
as like buns like a money in particular
and uh you know you still keep that when
you go back into your single-player game
so it's not a total loss so we rated
that one sort of true all right we had
one bonus test that I'd like to go out
on and this was drivers and animals in
this game are all drunk and yeah that's
true there they're definitely all of
them are drunk I don't know where they
all got their drivers test but thank you
the very first thing that happened to me
in this game was I spawned in hired a
gun for hire he immediately got mauled
by a cougar who then ran off and got hit
by a car and I just sat there laughing
for a couple of minutes the sandbox a
far cry just always entertains me it's
it's one of those games where I don't
mind if it breaks it's weird like
there's so many games where they break
and it's aggravating when this game
breaks I'm usually laughing my ass off
and I honestly find it to be a bit
endearing make sure you guys keep an eye
on gamespot.com
will be getting her hands on the game
before launch March 27th and we'll make
sure to bring you more important stuff
like where are the prepper stashes the
cool guns and maybe even some more tests
if you guys have some ideas of what you
want us to test next let us know in the
comments below and we'll try and get it
done for you
alright thanks for watching thanks
[Music]